it has been a somewhat surreal few days
in AI for so many reasons and the month
of May promises to be yet stranger and
according to this under the radar
article company insiders and government
officials tell of an imminent release of
new openai models and yes of course the
strangeness at the end of April was
Amplified by the gpt2 chatbot a mystery
model showcased and then withdrawn
within days but which I did get to test
I thought testing it would be a slightly
more appropriate response than doing an
all cap video claiming that AGI has
arrived I also want to bring in two
papers released in the last 24 hours 90
pages in total and read in full they
might be more significant than any rumor
you have heard first things first though
that article from Politico that I
mentioned and the context to this
article is this there was an AI safety
Summit in Bletchley last year near to
where I live actually in Southern
England some of the biggest players in
AI like meta and open AI promised the UK
government that the UK government could
safety test the frontier latest models
before they were released there's only
one slight problem they haven't done it
now you might say that's just part of
the course for big Tech but the article
also revealed some interesting Insider
gossip Politico spoke to a host many
company insiders Consultants lobbyists
and government officials they spoke
anonymously over several months and not
only did we learn that it's only Google
deep mine that have given the government
Early Access we also learned that open
AI didn't now somewhat obviously that
tells us that they have a new model and
that it's very near to release now I
very much doubt they're going to call it
GPT 5 and you can see more of my reasons
for that in the video you can see on
screen but I think it's more likely to
be something like GPT 4.5 optimized for
reason Ing and planning now some of you
might be thinking is that all the
evidence you've got that a GPT 4.5 will
be coming before GPT 5 well not quite
how about this MIT technology review
interview conducted with samman in the
last few days in a private discussion
samman was asked if he knew when the
next version of GPT is slated to be
released and he said calmly yes now
think about it if the model had months
and months more of Uncertain safety
testing you couldn't be that confident
about a release date think about what
happened to Google Gemini Ultra which
was delayed and delayed and delayed that
again points to a more imminent release
then another bit of secondhand evidence
this time from an AI Insider on patreon
we have a wonderful Discord and this
Insider at a Stanford event put a
question directly to samman very
recently this was a different Stanford
event to the one I'm about to also quote
from and in this response Sam wman
confirmed that he's personally using the
unreleased version of their new model
but enough of secondhand sources what
about another direct quote from Sam
Alman well here's some more evidence
released yesterday that rather than drop
a bombshell GPT 5 on us which I predict
to come somewhere between November and
January they're going to give us an
iterative GPT 4.5 first he doesn't want
to surprise us it does kind of suck to
ship a product that you're embarrassed
about but it's much better than the
alternative and in this case in
particular where I think we really owe
it to society to deploy tively
one thing we've learned is that Ai and
surprise don't go well together people
don't want to be surprised people want a
gradual roll out and the ability to
influence these systems that's how we're
going to do it now he might want to tell
that to open ai's recent former head of
developer relations he now works at
Google and said something I really
appreciate about Google's culture is how
transparent things are 30 days in I feel
like I have a great understanding of
where we are going from a model
perspective having line of sight on this
makes it so much easier to start
building compelling developer products
it almost sounds like the workers at
open AI often don't have a great
understanding of where they're going
from a model perspective now In fairness
samman did say that the current GPT 4
will be significantly dumber than their
new model cha GPT is not phenomenal like
chpt is mildly embarrassing at best GPT
4 is the dumbest model any of you will
ever ever have to use again by a lot but
you know it's like important to ship
early and often and we believe in
iterative deployment so agency and
reasoning focused GPT 4.5 coming soon
but GPT 5 not until the end of the year
or early next those are my predictions
now some people were saying that the
mystery gpt2 chatbot could be GPT 4.5 it
was released on a site used to compare
the different outputs of language models
and look here is it creating a beautiful
unicorn which llama 3 couldn't do now I
Fran Bally got ready a tweet saying that
super intelligence had arrived but
quickly had to delete it and not just
because other people were reporting that
they couldn't get decent unicorns and
not just because that exact unicorn
could be found on the web but the main
reason was that I was one of the lucky
ones to get in and test gpt2 chat B on
the arena before it was withdrawn I
could only do eight questions but I gave
it my standard handcrafted so not on the
web set of test questions spanning logic
theory of mind mathematics coding and
more its performance was pretty much
identical to GPT 4 Turbo there was one
question that it would get right more
often than GPT 4 Turbo but that could
have been noise so if this was a sneak
preview of GPT 4.5 I don't think it's
going to shock and stun the entire
industry so tempting as it was to bang
out a video saying that AI has arrived
in all caps I resisted the urge since
then other testers have found broadly
the same thing on language translation
the mystery gpt2 chatbot massively
underperforms Claude Opus and still
underperforms gp4 turbo on an extended
test of logic it does about the same as
Opus and gp4 turbo of course that still
does leave the possibility that it is an
open AI model a tiny one and one that
they might even release open weights
meaning anyone can use it and in that
case the impressive thing would be how
well it's performing despite it size
well if gpt2 chatbot is a smaller model
how could it possibly be even vaguely
competitive the secret source is the
data as James Becker of open AI said
it's not so much about tweaking model
configurations and hyperparameters nor
is it really about architecture or
Optimizer choices behavior is determined
by your data set it is the data set that
you are approximating to an incredible
degree in a later post he referred to
the flaws of Dary 3 and gp4 and also
flaws in video probably referring to the
at the time unreleased Sora and said
they arise from a lack of data in a
specific domain and in a more recent
post he said that while computer
efficiency was still super important
anything can be stay of the-art with
enough scale compute and eval hacking
now we'll get to evaluation and
Benchmark hacking in just a moment but
it does seem to me that there are more
and more hints that you can Brute Force
performance with enough compute and and
as mentioned a quality data set at least
to me it seems increasingly clear that
you can pay your way to top performance
unless open AI reveal something
genuinely shocking the performance of
meta's llama 3 8 billion 70 billion and
soon 400 billion show that they have
less of a secret Source than many people
had thought and as Mark Zuckerberg
hinted recently it could just come down
to which company blinks first who among
Google meta and Microsoft which provides
the compute for open AI is willing to
continue to spend tens or hundreds of
billions of dollars on new models if the
secret is simply the data set that would
make less and less sense you over the
last few years I think there was this
issue of um GPU production yeah right so
even companies that had the money to pay
for the gpus couldn't necessarily get as
many as they wanted because there was
there were all these Supply constraints
now I think that's sort of getting less
so now I think you're seeing a bunch of
companies think about wow we should just
like really invest a lot of money in
building out these things and I think
that will go for um for some period of
time there is a capital question of like
okay at what point does it stop being
worth it to put the capital in but I
actually think before we hit that you're
going to run into energy constraints now
if you're curious about energy and data
center constraints check out my why does
open aai need a Stargate supercomputer
video released 4 weeks ago but before we
leave data centers and data set I must
draw your attention to this paper
released in the last 24 hours it's
actually a brilliant paper from scale AI
what they did was create a new and
refined version of a benchmark that's
used all the time to test the
mathematical reasoning capabilities of
AI models and there were at least four
fascinating findings relevant to all new
models coming out this year the first
the context and they worried that many
of the latest models had seen the
Benchmark questions in their training
data that's called contamination because
of course it contaminates the results on
the test the original test had 8,000
questions but what they did was create a
thousand new questions of similar
difficulty now if contamination wasn't a
problem then models should perform just
as well with the new questions as with
the old and obviously that didn't happen
for the mistol and fi family of models
performance notably lagged on the new
test compared to the old one whereas
fair's fair for GPT 4 and Claude
performance was the same or better on
the new fresh test but here's the thing
the authors figured out that that wasn't
just about Which models had seen the
questions in their training data they
say that mistol large which performed
exactly the same was just as likely to
have seen those questions as Mixr
instruct which way underperformed so
what could explain the difference well
the bigger models generalize even if
they have seen the questions they learn
more from them and can generalize to new
questions and here's another supporting
quote they lean toward the hypo
hypthesis that sufficiently strong large
language models learn Elementary
reasoning ability during training you
could almost say that benchmarks get
more reliable when you're talking about
the very biggest models next and this
seems to be a running theme in popular
ml benchmarks the GSM 8K designed for
high schoolers has a few errors they
didn't say how many but the answers were
supposed to be positive integers and
they weren't the new Benchmark however
passed through three layers of quality
checks third they provide extra theories
as to why models might overperform on
benchmarks compared to the real world
that's not just about data contamination
it could be that model Builders designed
data sets that are similar to test
questions after all if you were trying
to bake in reasoning to your model what
kind of data would you collect plenty of
exams and textbooks so the more similar
their data set is in nature not just
exact match to benchmarks the more your
benchmark performance will be elevated
compared to simple real world use think
about it it could be an inadvertent
thing where enhancing the overall
smartness of the model comes at the cost
of overperforming on benchmarks and
whatever you think about benchmarks that
does seem to work here Sebastian bck
lead author of The Five series of models
I've interviewed him for AI insiders and
he said this even on those 1,000 neverbe
seen questions 53 mini which is only 3.8
billion parameters performed within
about 8 or 9% of GP GT4 turbo now we
don't know the parameter count of GT4
turbo but it's almost certainly orders
of magnitude bigger so training on high
quality data as we have seen definitely
works even if it slightly skews
Benchmark performance but one final
observation from me about this paper I
read almost all the examples that the
paper gave from this new Benchmark and
as the paper mentions they involve basic
addition subtraction multiplication and
division after all the original test was
designed for youngsters you can pause
and try the questions yourself but
despite them being lots of words they
aren't actually hard at all so my
question is this why are models like
Claude 3 Opus still getting any of these
questions wrong remember they're scoring
around 60% in graduate level expert
reasoning the GP QA if Claude 3 Opus for
example can get questions right that
phds struggle to get right with Google
and 30 minutes why on Earth with five
short examples can they not get these
basic high school questions right either
there are still flaws in the test or
these models do have a limit in terms of
how much they can generalize now if you
like this kind of analysis feel free to
sign up to my completely free newsletter
it's called signal to noise and the link
is in the description and if you want to
chat in person about it the regional
networking on the AI insiders Discord
server is popping off there are meetings
being arranged not only in London but
Germany the Midwest Ireland San
Francisco Madrid Brazil and it goes on
and on honestly I've been surprised and
honored by the number of spontaneous
meetings being arranged across the world
but it's time arguably for the most
exciting development of the week Med
Gemini from Google it's a 58 page paper
but the tldr is this the latest series
of Gemini models from Google are more
than competitive with doctors at
providing medical answers and even in
areas where they can't quite perform
like in surgery they can be amazing
assistant in a world in which millions
of people die due to Medical errors this
could be a tremendous breakthrough Med
Gemini contains a number of Innovations
it wasn't just rerunning the same test
on a new model for example you can
inspect how confident a model is in its
answer by trolling through the raw
outputs of a model called the logic you
could see how high probability they find
their answers if they gave confident
answers you would submit that as the
answer they use this technique by the
way for the original Gemini launch where
they claimed to be GPT 4 but that's
another story anyway if the model is not
confident you can get the model to
generate search queries to resolve those
conflicts train it in other words to use
Google seems appropriate then you can
feed that additional context provided by
the web back into the model to see if
it's confident now but that was just one
Innovation what about this fine-tuning
Loop to oversimplify they get the model
to Output answers again using the help
of search and then the outputs that had
correct answers were used to fine-tune
the models now that's not perfect of
course because sometimes you can get the
right answer with the wrong logic but it
worked up to a certain point at least
just last week by the way on patreon I
described how this reinforced in context
learning can be applied to multiple
domains other Innovations come from the
incredible long context abilities of the
Gemini 1.5 series of models with that
family of models you can troll through a
700,000 word electronic health record
now imagine a human doctor trying to do
the same thing I remember on the night
of Gemini 1.5s release calling it the
biggest news of the day even more
significant than Sora and I still stand
by that so what were the results well of
course a state of-the-art performance on
Med QA that assesses your ability to
diagnose diseases the doctor pass rate
by the way is around 60% and how about
this for a mini theme of the video when
they carefully analyze the questions in
the Benchmark they found that 7.4% of
the questions have quality issues things
like lacking key information incorrect
ansers or multiple plausible
interpretations so just in this video
alone we've seen multiple Benchmark
issues and I collected a thread of other
Benchmark issues on Twitter the positive
news though is just how good these
models are getting at things like
medical note summarization and clinical
referral letter generation but I don't
want to detract from the headline which
is just how good these models are
getting at diagnosis here you can see
Med Gemini with search way outperforming
expert clinicians with search by the way
when errors from the test were taken out
performance bumped up to around 93% and
the authors can't wait to augment their
models with additional data things like
data from consumer wearables genomic
information nutritional data and
environmental factors and as a quite
amusing aside it seems like Google and
Microsoft are in a tussle to throw shade
at each other's methods in a positive
spirit Google contrast their approach to
Med prompt from Microsoft saying that
their approach is principled and it can
be easily extended to more complex
scenarios Beyond Med QA now you might
say that's harsh but Microsoft earlier
had said that their Med prompt approach
shows GPC 4's ability to outperform
Google's model that was fine-tuned
specifically for medical applications it
outperforms on the same benchmarks by a
significant margin well Google have
obviously won up them by reach new
state-of-the-art performances on 10 of
14 benchmarks Microsoft had also said
that their approach has simple prompting
and doesn't need more sophisticated and
expensive methods Google shot back
saying they don't need complex
specialized prompting and their approach
is best honestly this is competition
that I would encourage may they long
compete for Glory in this medical arena
in case you're wondering because Gemini
is a multimodal model it can see images
too you can interact with patients and
ask them to to provide images the model
can also interact with primary care
physicians and ask for things like
X-rays and most surprisingly to me it
can also interact with surgeons to help
boost performance yes that's video
assistance during live surgery of course
they haven't yet deployed this for
ethical and safety reasons but Gemini is
already capable of assessing a video
scene and helping with surgery for
example by answering whether the
critical view of safety criteria are
being met Do you have a great view of
the gallbladder for example and Med
Gemini could potentially guide surgeons
in real time during these complex
procedures for not only improved
accuracy but patient outcomes notice the
Nuance of the response from Gemini oh
the lower third of the gallbladder is
not dissected off the cystic plate and
the authors list many improvements that
they could have made they just didn't
have time to make for example the models
were searching the Wild web and one
option would be to restrict the search
results to just more authoritative
medical sources the catch though is that
this model is not open-sourced and isn't
widely available due to they say the
safety implications of unmonitored use I
suspect the commercial implications of
open sourcing Gemini also had something
to do with it but here's the question I
would set for you we know that hundreds
of thousands or even millions of people
die due to Medical mistakes around the
world so if and when Med Gemini 2 3 or 4
becomes unambiguously better than all
clinicians at diagnosing diseases then
at what point is it unethical not to at
least deploy them in assisting
clinicians that's definitely something
at least to think about overall this is
exciting and excellent work so many
congratulations to the team and in a
world that is seeing some Stark misuses
of AI as well as increasingly autonomous
deployment of AI like this autonomous
tank the fact that we can get
breakthroughs like this is genuinely
uplifting thank you so much for watching
to the end and have a wonderful day